yo what's up y'all sure man now is my
man DJ people a cab we all las vegas
with you be there's no joke up in here
975 I got the key to this station like
Nike presented to me you know you gotta
be a big [__] again this is where it's
at now 75 plays in today's hottest music
man bootleg cam on your radio and in
studio we got my favorite rapper ever
ever exist man one of the greatest ever
doing nasty houses in the building put
up my brother what is good sir I'm good
at math I got the bus fresh off the tour
bus from LA cover from LA sup man of
course you got the new album with damian
marley get messy relatives yes sir yes
sir how was the tour run be man towards
been great man we just left for LA last
night's sold-out show crazy show the
dread got it in with me it's a beautiful
thing yes definitely man definitely now
I know you know you and Damien hooked up
for a road design on it welcome to
Jamrock is that kind of how you know you
guys you guys did that track did that
kind of you know set up everything for
the album yeah that track right there
just met him and saw how you worked i
was a fan already and we just work real
easy i wanted to work with a mcginnis Oh
made it happen it was like I cold us to
a whole out yeah yeah cuz a lot of times
you always hear like these these albums
and hip hop again you know whether it be
the firm NAS be delivering with the
super albums Clara you always hear about
like ice cube and Ray dropping an album
or you know all these news but nas and
damian marley I didn't think would
actually come out is hearing it is not
disappoint Thank You Man yeah a lot of
people today think it was coming they
came and we had we just dropped it man
we feel good
you guys are performing at the joint at
hard rock yeah can they expect I mean
how much of the new album are you gonna
do how much of your material are you
gonna do I'll be you know that's full of
everybody to come and see you kind of
keep it under wraps a little bit but you
could imagine what we do you know jr.
God does his records i do my records but
we definitely are you definitely do the
new album out there you know it is good
to do new records with people that
really don't know all the salty it's a
good feeling that's what's up now I'm
gonna be at the show tonight and I gotta
ask you me yes anyway you can do new
york state of mind let's talk okay i'm
just not the greatest ever to me i have
not done none of the really the records
from my omaticaya but i got our talk
okay all right this that's what's up now
NAS I gotta ask you man I'm like you
know like a kind of a hip-hop geek
myself yeah you know this is like my
radio you know plateau right here
interviewing naz two questions I want to
ask you for all that you know this you
saw this dude keep a hip-hop keeping his
head Oh quick got to a mint lost tapes
the first lost tapes was classic thank
you all the nas heads trying to figure
out what happened with lost tapes to and
never dropped when we went on with that
um I don't got a lot of songs that
really didn't make no album is just
sitting around that got lost so I got
enough Ashley for a lost tapes two and
three by now so I just got to set it up
put them together 12 songs for the point
album 12 songs for another and figure it
out that's all that is all it takes but
definitely you might you I hope you see
a lost tapes two or three I'm whole
today now a lot of talking like was made
it you know you weren't on the blueprint
3 and you weren't on a purple tape to
you know a lot a lot of a lot of Doozers
was hoping that you'll be on each of one
of those records and of course you had
two people J um what's your relationship
with hope like now you guys like you
know you guys still cool
cool as a fan now for something yeah
yeah cuz grown men romance stuff yes
that's what it is now I do have
something here from my boss mystery to
Salisbury she wanted to present you with
something man what's that what you got
right here is the key to hot 97.5 it now
you got the key to the station my dude
wow that's major right there Wow yo
thank you yes take you out to the
program directly with sarita salisbury
the key to hot 97 file your hands right
here man yeah and it's heavy heavy as
hell that's what it is made our man I
throw it yo y'all know what I did to me
just now ha ha ha ha maybe york state of
mind I've got you good man that's not
music to my ears right there of course
you're gonna be at a hot topic today
yeah signing autographs six o'clock on
the dot yeah yes sir so make sure
everybody comes out show some love get
your autograph pictures whatever now I
got your kid in the station people do
you know what this is the key to the
station is major baby I gotta see this
can we put this on Linus um yeah hold up
show up showing on cam right here space
yes so now that you've got the key you
can come in here after hours you know
next time you're in Vegas you got you
know oh god what do you need to bring
through somewhere you have you got
getting station is going to bottom hop
on the air whatever you want this is
crazy do whatever you must man know why
you too bad we had a few people on
Twitter that we're asking a few
questions yeah of course a lot of people
will have you as you know one of the
greatest MCS of all time who is your
your top five it's funny mad I don't
really I don't have a top five is too
many people I life with different
reasons I like Karis one right Kim I
skew um b.i.g pocket Scarface um the
Garvey kool g rap cane slick rick um on
the outcast oh I got you not too many
people I love ya hey are you ever gonna
drop them unauthorized I might be here
is one i heard that that might happen
okay i was supposed to put that in about
two to three albums ago so um I don't
know hey on the solo front what's it are
you already working on the next album is
that even in your site right now I'll
tell you I did one day I did I did two
songs one day and I stopped myself
because I was just had this album with
Damien let's really want to get this out
make money dedicated although a hundred
percent and you don't have to refinish
I'll talk and you know go around the
world and hopefully all my kid it out
this year later on the [__] what
happened there's a lot to do a lot of
like a whole new
generation Raptors that are going to
repression right now yes you are getting
prepared a lot or this dude Jake Olson
compared to you a lot of you have you
heard anything from j Cole the Jays new
artist ya wouldn't think of what do you
think of the comparisons you think that
their own they're just yo I love it I
love it has anybody you're feeling yeah
yeah I'm doing it I'm telling Jake Bohm
I'm feeling jail electronic room Drake
to me is still a new artists right now
for sure so Drake is that dude oh those
are my three those are my three right
thing one more super hip hop question 40
40 pounds nas what's up man DJ premier
said that he is like ready to do a whole
outlook min we will get that happen bro
primo nah I'm straight up premier
Premier good more for me oh I mean yeah
I'd love that we had it that is like
every every hip-hop hands wet dream
right there I love that MADD 4 beta man
s permit even if you just you just did
like a whole like your next album with
premier he brought mark compressor over
hello I eight min i'll buy I five
million copies of that I had money yeah
hey I think there that's a line up and
at that line up this classy that's what
70 amen do I appreciate you coming
through with an honor to talk to you
brother hey thanks show bula care much
love to yes sir to these artists right
here that's what you are artist yeah I
got a great bright future ahead of yall
hopefully i'll spit i feel your passion
in the music i don't know i got your CD
i'm gonna listen to that i don't know if
you got a CD homie but I love your ish
we'll see what we can do yes I was in
Vegas tonight okay ladies needs a single
man oh my god oh my god I'm single so
sing late
make sure you get it down we doing the
damn thing tonight sir I almost even at
at the show yes through your state of
mind gotch new york state of mind yes i
got 75 yes right you got the lion was
that not how are you going through my
friends throw it